meantime ccsd school board members
holding a special hearing to talk about
this increase in violence on their
campuses a news now has been on the
forefront of reporting incidents at our
schools we've requested reports on just
how many violent acts happened this
school year madison kimbrough has those
numbers she joins us live in the
newsroom with more mass and these
numbers are shocking
yeah david there have been over 5 300
reports of violence since august and
harassment and threats are the biggest
problem
i've had a grandson that was attacked at
our review a pacific school
and nothing took place we don't want my
next set of grandchildren to go through
the same thing this is just one of many
concerned parents and grandparents
speaking out at ccsd's board trustee
meeting on their school violence policy
in a 4-3 vote it was determined that
there needs to be a massive overview of
policy regulations as student violence
has increased according to clark county
education association how many educators
have we lost due to
them not wanting to deal with this how
is this violence in schools affecting
other areas of the district in documents
from the school district obtained by
eight news now it breaks down the
violent acts reported this school year
more than 300 assault and battery
incidents with over 1400 fights
harassment and threats over 2 300. a lot
of these kids that are coming here and
they're starting fights you know they're
living in in violent environments or
things like that so their you know
highest ideals are not being met as for
staffing trustee katie williams noted
the district only has about 186 police
officers for 305 000 students i spoke to
a ccsd student who shared with me what
it's like at his school noting that he
has seen an improvement in security this
week there were two groups of kids that
were throwing stuff stuff at each other
and it looked like they were about to
fight before it was broken up by a
campus monitor
and there was actually one more campus
monitor that was hired at my school in
the past week so now we have five in
total
and a bigger discussion will take place
on march 10th you can find the 128-page
violence report on eight newsnow dot com
it list dates and schools where the
incidents were reported and what actions
were taken reporting live in the
newsroom madison kimbrough live local
now